[MUSIC PLAYING]
One of the great things that
culture and art is capable of
is actually giving
a physical language
to something that is, otherwise,
highly mediated or abstract,
meaning that something
like climate change
is very difficult to understand
because I can't touch it.
I can't measure it.
It's not like a--
it's not like a ball in my hand.
It was actually,
for the first time,
possible to sail the Northwest
Passage on the western side
of the North Pole,
connecting the two oceans
and shortening the
way of sailing.
And it's been long time
debated whether this
will ever, ever be possible.
And now, with global warming
and the melting of the ice,
it suddenly is possible.
And, in that sense,
I thought this was
a nice topic I'm interested in.
And the fact that, when
you see satellite pictures
of the ocean, airplane pictures
of this particular ocean,
you see the ice
scattered around,
and you realize that,
these white ice sheets,
they look like small islands
or small pieces of land.
And, if you wanted
to cross, you'll
have to jump from
one to the other.
And that had interested me.
I had actually made drawings
of that in my studio,
and I was just
interested in the fact
that a lot of what we
know as being stable
has become unstable.
And a lot of the
things that we take
for granted as out of
the reach of change
are, in fact, now changing.
So the world, as we know it,
has become a lot more relative.
And, with regards to the whole
sort of idea of nanotechnology,
I thought, OK, this is also
interesting because, in a way,
nano is about making what we
could not see before visible
or making the invisible visible.
As an artist, I'm trying to
sort out, well, what kind of art
or what type of artistic
interventions in the world
can I do to bring about a more
action-driven relationship
with the climate
or an opportunity
for you to see, well, turning
your knowledge into action
is actually something that is
a little easier than I thought
it would be.
And, actually, the
climate is not as abstract
as I thought it would be.
It's right here in front of me.
I can touch it, and
it is understandable.
And it is not like big science.
It's quite specific and so on.
I think that art
alone should not
be the one who communicates
the explicified version of what
climate science is, but it
is one of the great things
that I think is exciting
to work with, as an artist,
is to make things, which we
know explicit as something
as we feel, giving
it you could call it
an emotional narrative,
besides the sort
of data-driven,
data-driven narrative.
The artwork here came
out of my interest
in various other artworks
to work with geometry
and these more random shapes.
You could say these sort of
puddles or pools or ice sheets.
And I am actually, in
this case, particularly
interested in the
fact, when you look up,
you obviously see the
reflection of the ground
because it's a mirror.
And you look up, and
you see the ground.
And, to that extent,
it is actually
like a ceiling, which has these
small islands, if you want,
of the ground.
And I've worked with
that a few times,
but you could also see
them as stepping stones.
Should we be in a situation
where the South Pole melts--
and the chances are significant.
That is not just
some crazy idea.
It actually is.
That probably means that half of
Boston is completely underwater
and not just a little bit,
like literally underwater.
And going around
on the campus is
likely to be jumping from one
stepping stone to the other.
So, when I talk
about these things,
I talk about the kind of
way that a space contains
not just us, but also our
action and our ability
to interact and share things.
And I think art can be
a part of that equation
in artistic
interventions and amplify
what makes the space better,
amplify the fact that we should
be open-minded to the extent
of understanding that spaces
actually have social
potential as well.
And, sometimes, you
need a language.
So you need sort of a quality
in a space, which simply
triggers that sort of social or
that generous type of activity.
[MUSIC PLAYING]